look at this he goes up in a hot air  balloon to i mean be all watch this he's  in a [ __ ] little a little pod he goes  all the way up this guy  part of the free fall he was going to  lose consciousness for that's what he  practiced oh my god so look it's oh my  god up and up and up is he just a thrill  seeker or is this a scientific piece it  was all put on by red bull but my  [ __ ]  it's all rebel i mean sponsored by red  bull to drop in human beings  and you're going to pass out look at  this sponsored by red bull nerve wrath  when he opens the pod door but what is  this for is this for red bull promotion  look at this wow how nerve-wracking is  this look at look could you imagine and  then you just have to i can't even get  into a cold bath zenith and red bull oh  this is literally the most likely there  is  my [ __ ] is pucker tight  this is this is the most somebody get me  a  oh washcloth god